hey 42 here the small british crown
dependency of the isle of man
is famous for many things the monks cat
with no tail
tt motorbike races and smoked herring
kippers
but in the early 1930s the island
briefly became
famous for a small undead mammal called
jeff
and to this day residents still scream
in terror
if you mention the name of jeff the
talking mongoose
hey well okay maybe they don't scream
they probably just roll their eyes tut
and say
get out of my kipper shop nonetheless
jeff the mongoose captured the
imagination of the tabloid press
he ended up in law books tarnished
reputations
got people fired inspired lawsuits
wasted the time of several esteemed
academics and was instrumental in the
bbc overhauling their staff policies
but to find out who jeff the mongoose
was and why he was
on dares we need to go back to september
of 1931
when the irving family started hearing
scratching
barking growling spitting and blowing
noises
coming from the rafters and skirting
boards
of their cosy family farmhouse at
cashion's gap
on the isle of man everyone knows
rage shadow legends by now but did you
know
it's raid's second anniversary that's
right it's been two years since raid
burst onto the scene
and completely took over mobile gaming
and since then
raid's only gotten bigger and only
gotten better
for me it's when i'm travelling and i
have free time to kill
you can literally play from anywhere and
yes that includes on the toilet
i'd definitely be crusader from the
sacred order
i mean who wouldn't want to be a
medieval knight with a massive sword
what i like best about the game is the
campaign mode with constant quest
updates and a huge variety of locations
there's always something new and
exciting around every corner
i've found the trick is learning when to
use your most powerful abilities
and when to save them for a trickier
opponent
as i mentioned earlier this month is
raid's two-year anniversary
they've got six straight weeks of
anniversary events and tournaments
running from the 1st of march all the
way to the middle of april
all of them with insane prizes to win if
you haven't joined the raid community
already
then what are you waiting for raid is
huge it's only getting bigger
and better so if you're looking to get a
huge head start in raid
all you have to do is click the link in
the description or scan my qr code
and if you're a new player you'll get a
free epic champion
jotun who is amazing for the doom tower
by the way
you'll also get 100k silver 50 gems
and the free ancient shards so you can
summon
awesome champions as soon as you get in
the game all this treasure will be
waiting for you
here but be quick because these awards
will only be available
for the next 30 days once you're in you
can find me in-game under the name 42
and if you're fast enough you can join
my clan good luck
and i'll see you in game farmer james
irving
his wife margaret and their 13 year old
daughter
vara were really starting to lose sleep
over the ghostly noises
so james took the only logical step he
could to deal with the sounds
he tried to poison it trap it
and shoot it with a rifle whatever it
was believe it or not none of these
methods worked
so james attempted a variety of animal
and bird noises
to see if the voice would respond
amazingly
it not only responded but mimicked each
call
perfectly vora tried the same thing with
songs and
nursery rhymes and their mysterious
guest
happily performed them all for her in a
voice which was apparently
two octaves above the normal human range
one night however jeff decided to
introduce himself properly
and from that point on the irvings
couldn't shut the skinny little bastard
up
he revealed he was a ghost who'd taken
the form of a mongoose
then the supernatural mongoose declared
he was 80 years old
and was born in new delhi in 1852
that's right the furry booger had
somehow travelled 7000 miles
as the mongoose flies to live inside the
walls
of a remote farmhouse on the isle of man
when the family quizzed him on how he
was able to talk he said he was
an extra extra clever mongoose so he
obviously wasn't the most modest of
carnivorous mammals
mind you he didn't seem to be too
confident about his looks either
i am a freak he told the irvings if you
saw me
you'd faint you'd be petrified mummified
turned into stone or a pillar of salt
by this point james was feeling a little
guilty about trying to shoot and poison
jeff after all he seemed like a fairly
decent critter
so he apologized and from that point on
they were best of friends
jeff guarded the house would chase away
mice
extinguished a stove if the irvings
forgot
wake them up if they overslept and
deliver rabbits
as gifts for the family which jeff
proudly pointed out
that he'd strangled to death which is
nice
i suppose i usually prefer my stewie
ingredients not strangled to death
but hey it's the ford that counts as for
the irvings they were happy to repay the
favor
they filled a saucer with bacon sausages
bananas and
chocolate which are obviously a
mongoose's favorite food groups
and suspended it from the ceiling so
jeff could help himself when no one was
watching
which is important when you're a
self-conscious supernatural talking
mongoose
they even took him for walks to the
market during which
jeff would talk incessantly about any
subject that took his fancy
although he always conveniently made
sure he was completely obscured by a
hedge
just in case anyone caught a peek of his
hideous features
now by this point i'd completely
understand if you're thinking
42 is really out of ideas he's just
started making up bollocks about a
talking mongoose
but i'd like to clarify i'm not making
any of this up
the irvings definitely were but i'm not
it was only a matter of time until a
swarm of tabloid journalists were
heading to the isle of man
hoping for the merest glimpse of the
creature or at best a full warts and all
interview featuring some of jeff's kiss
and tell secrets
and maybe even a full colour centerfold
in skimpy mongoose laundry
mind you a newspaper interview with jeff
would have to carry
a parental advisory warning he was
rather prone to mood swings you see
and could go from charming sophisticated
mongoose about town
to the kind of mongoose who'd stick a
broken glass in your face whilst looking
at his girlfriend
and by irving family accounts jeff's
conversation were littered with more
f and c words than your average
tarantino film
in fact his comments to voira was so
unpleasant
that james and margaret had to move her
bed into their room
until jeff learned to be a little less
filthy
as ridiculous as all of this sounds some
residents of the isle of man
really did believe there was something
strange in the neighborhood
so they decided to call harry price
paranormal investigator mainly because
none of the real ghostbusters would be
born for another few decades
mind you price was very much the peter
venkman of his day
having worked on a number of
high-profile cases
such as his celebrated investigation
into the haunted
tourist kiosk at the top of the eiffel
tower
things kept going missing you see
souvenirs
keepsakes cheap jewelry so
it was clearly the work of a malevolent
spirit
or a shoplifter or perhaps a malevolent
spirit who enjoyed a bit of shoplifting
long story short price was well
experienced
at investigating so-called supernatural
occurrences
that were most likely complete and utter
bollocks
before price arrived on the scene he
asked james irving for more information
about
jeff so he sent him his diary still
available today in the university of
london archives
it goes into detail about how jeff had a
great facility
for foreign languages he suddenly
started speaking russian one day
wasn't too shabby at arabic understood
sign language
could recite four lines of a welsh poem
and sing
two verses of a spanish song
he also seemed to be the james bond of
the mongoose world
when not annoying the piss out of the
irvings with songs from around the world
in falsetto
he ventured outside to spy on other
farms
collect gossip from the locals and
reported his findings back to the family
the irvings thought this was terrific of
course
so imagine their joy when jeff suddenly
developed psychic powers and could tell
them
what was going on 10 miles away without
leaving the comfort
of his skirting board now
these stories were obviously completely
and utterly
ludicrous so harry price decided not to
waste his time any further
and immediately booked himself a ticket
to the isle of man
he informed the irvings that he was on
the way
but barely had time to dust off his
proton pack
before a letter arrived saying that jeff
by a massive coincidence had suddenly
gone missing
honestly you just couldn't make it up
well actually you could because they did
nonetheless a month later in july 1935
price decided to pack his pke meter
regardless
and headed to the isle of man to see
this mongoose
in the ghostly flesh for himself
he asked his friend richard lambert an
editor at the bbc
to come along as a witness you can
hardly blame him
if there was so much as a fleeting
chance i was going to see an apparition
of a talking mongoose
i'd want a bloody witness too
unfortunately
when they arrived jeff still wasn't in a
talking mood
so james gave them a tour of the house
instead
he showed them cracks and peepholes in
the walls
from where jeff would mutter rude and
embarrassing things
and here is where the story begins to
unravel
you see for a few years newspapers and a
few locals
had speculated the entire phenomenon
was down to voira and she was able to
produce
jeff's voice due to a hidden natural
talent for ventriloquism and sure enough
price's big smoking gun in the case was
realizing the space between the exterior
stone walls
and interior wooden walls acted as a
huge
microphone and if he spoke into the
cracks between the paneling
his voice would reverberate through the
walls and be carried to
every room in the house needless to say
price and lambert were both pretty
unimpressed with the evidence
and the fact jeff suddenly returned to
cashion's gap
on the night they left did nothing to
appease
their suspicions apparently jeff told
james that he disliked price because he
had his doubting
cap on but even so the magnanimous
mongoose decided to make plasticine
impressions
of his own paws and teeth to prove his
existence
once and for all and price
in turn did what any of us would do with
evidence of a non-existent
mongoose ghost he sent it to one of
britain's most distinguished zoologists
reginald's pocket at the natural history
museum
we can only imagine what pukkik fought
when these items showed up
probably whatever the 1930s equivalent
of wtf was
he spent very little time determining
the teeth marks and paw prints
had most likely come from a dog
specifically
a sheep dog and even more specifically a
sheepdog called mona
who just so happened to be owned by the
irvings
i'm sure it was just a coincidence
jeff wasn't going to take such flagrant
denial
lying down or whatever mongooses do
he told the irvings he'd plucked a hair
from his own back
and placed it inside an ornament upon
the mantelpiece
sure enough there it was and james
forward it
to sir julian huxley an esteemed
evolutionary biologist
first director of unesco and eugenicist
huxley had more important things to do
than examining the supposed hair of an
undead mongoose
like you know deciding who was too
stupid to pass on their genes
yeah and so he forwarded the sample to
naturalist
francis duncan smith after a quick
comparison with hairs of various species
duncan declared with confidence that the
specimen could not have come from a
mongoose
and was most likely from a long-haired
dog
that's right mona again the irving's
suspect sheepdog mona spent so much time
pretending to be a mongoose
she probably forgot she was a dog
in 1936 price and lambert published a
full account of their findings
in the book the haunting of kashin's gap
although they never explicitly denied
the existence of jeff
the evidence they laid out was pretty
damning
and ultimately left the whole voira
being a two-bit ventriloquist
mumbling expletives at herself into the
walls theory
the most likely after james died in 1945
margaret and voiro were forced to sell
the farm at a very low price
because for some reason people weren't
keen to buy a farmhouse haunted by a
foul-mouthed mongoose
i don't know about you but i think i'd
be the first through the doors of the
estate agents for that one
it was eventually purchased by actor
leslie graham who later sold a story to
the press
claiming he'd shot and killed poor jeff
he even provided a body but voira
shot his story down in flames saying
that it was most certainly
not jeff being both the wrong size and
colour to be
their famous family phantasm which must
have infuriated graham as it's thought
he only claimed to be jeff's murderer
in order to end all the urban legends
associated with his new home
vara however was having none of it
during an interview in later life
she still maintained jeff was real and
was dogmatic in her belief
all the way up to her death in 2005.
so was jeff simply a product of wara's
imagination
well yes probably but can we blame her
after all she was living in a really
isolated farmhouse on a really isolated
island
with very very little contact with the
outside world
70 years before the invention of netflix
zoom
and disney plus in the end it was
probably just a case of her making her
own entertainment
but what really happened at cashion's
gap in the 1930s
i guess we'll never truly know
thanks for watching thanks again to raid
shadow legends for sponsoring this video
don't forget to check it out using the
link below